for example can you google
uh uh uh tyler do me a favor google
what it call how much energy does mining
a bitcoin uh uh take
so apparently it's more energy
okay stay right there let me just read
that real quick
uh uh if you want to uh uh
go back go back real quick uh okay so
business insider is not a communist yet
i mean i know we're going after business
insiders got a bad reputation with
whatever's going on but
bitcoin mining consumes around 91
terawatt hours of electricity annually
okay bitcoin mining
that's more annual electricity
used than of all of finland which is a
country of five and a half million
people that's almost half a percent of
all of the electricity consumption
worldwide and a 10 times jump from just
five years ago
so this isn't a
you know
reddit crazy you know
a guy that's saying this so go back go
go into the article let's read a little
bit more
go all the way to the top let me just
read this out bitcoinmeister consumes uh
then globally and seven times google's
total usage new report says and google
is the number one search engine go a
little lower
uh go a little over half a percent okay
consumption according to new york times
that's roughly seven times on google
bitcoin's negative environmental impact
is expected to become a bigger issue as
cryptocurrency gains more popularity
okay by the way i see the fact
if new york times is saying this and
they're linking it to environmental
impact you already know where this is
going next seymour so go a little lower
go a little lower see what else they're
saying about this it is difficult to
measure exactly how much energy bitcoin
and consumes but a new analyst by the
new york times shared some staggering
info input okay and that's the stuff
that we just read right now so it's not
um
you know it's not just one person saying
it or two people saying that sure i'm
really trying to find out for myself
if we're going in a direction right now
where
uh
we keep printing money okay which has
been the strategy for the last 24 months
okay and the printing of money is not
left and right bush started it back in
the days with you know we we can talk
about quantitative easing that started
with
uh who's the first green span was it
green
so hey quantitative easing is actually a
good thing you know we go buy give money
to the banks and they buy shitty
business that's out of business but
you're putting money in there and
hopefully the money is going to go to
the middle income
and then eventually realize the more
they're doing that inflation next thing
you know we got 6.2 percent we can't
wait to see what the numbers are going
to be next so for me i i i would like to
see a
potential different currency that holds
everybody accountable that you cannot
manipulate specifically the government
cannot so it would be kind of cool to
have a different currency some said hey
we're going to go to gold standard peter
schiff gold standard nothing's happened
with gold the last 18 months i've owned
gold nothing's happened with gold in the
last 18 months right so
if there is a possibility of us going on
something that publicly you can count
and they can't print that'd be a
beautiful thing
but the fact that it takes that much
energy
in today's climate don't you see that as
an issue i don't and in fact um
if you look at bitcoin mining versus
what is going on in the rest of the
world like you're ignoring like yes
google and google is a big player but
they're not the only player if you look
at the entire global economy and what
they are doing in order to bootstrap
whatever we call the global financial
system so all of these things all these
players they're using exponentially more
energy than than bitcoin now here's my
problem again with with bitcoin btc is
that what are we doing with all that
energy on btc what we're essentially
doing is securing a bunch of coins that
are sitting on people's
paper wallets or ledger nanos or
whatever you know they're sitting there
they're not doing it they're not
creating anything with that money and
this is a problem for me too this is why
i actually argue that the btc community
has become
bourgeoisie whatever they're they're
very um
they've got a communist
pension to their to their behavior
they're not building things with bitcoin
they're not using bitcoin as a tool to
disrupt the actual economy and so it
does become a problem then it does
become wasteful if this is just securing
what's in my wallet that's that is a
problem and it's it's not a problem for
me to to go out and physically change
for someone else it's incumbent upon me
to build business use cases that that
supersede that so imagine if what i was
doing with bitcoin was replacing twitter
for example twitter's a giant nightmare
of a company they're a terrible company
but everybody uses them because
everybody's there but they're they're
also very wasteful think about how much
server space is actually exist just to
keep twitter online now if we were to
move over to bitcoin and bsv for example
has the the twitch network which you
have an account as i do yeah i do i
spoke to the founder of it him and i
went back and forth
uh i had different interests with them
but yeah yeah i do have an account with
them and so
so what they've done is they are they
are putting everything on chain in the
stack it's it's up in bitcoin it runs in
bitcoin it's not using other
infrastructure so we can ignore we can
eliminate amazon web services and
microsoft azure and all these other
things that are also consuming a lot of
energy but it also has the added benefit
of extreme censorship resistance people
can have political opinions that are
maybe unsavory but can't be deleted just
because jack dorsey or this new goon ceo
can uh you know well i don't i don't
like the sound of that and it's it's all
on chain it's it's
secured by proof of work and again this
proof of work this brute forcing of
ideas so imagine the hash we talked
about brute forcing hashes imagine brute
forcing every idea and making every node
around the world use that power use that
energy to to take conflicting ideas
speak to speak to the audience as if
they're a fifth grader right now because
you went to la la i know i i so come
back and simplify for us let me go back
to the question here's a question
if it requires this much energy that
people say requires you want to use the
example of twitter it's seven times
google which means twitter's probably
freaking fantastic nothing it's nothing
compared to google right i mean you
can't even compare it to it's probably
700 times
twitter if not more right so that
comparison argument somebody might find
a leak and poke it and say i don't know
what by what you're saying here all i'm
going back to is remember i would love
to see an alternative to fiat currency i
think most people would love that where
the government cannot just say
let's go mine 50 million more bitcoins
you can't like that right so we
don't have to worry about all the other
stuff
why is this constant conversation about
how much energy it requires to mine a
bitcoin
because people aren't focused on what
you can create with that cost people are
just looking at the cost and saying that
is a that is awful consumption and if
you just look at the consumption i agree
yeah and and i agree to the point that
people aren't creating disruptive things
with their blockchain right let me
restate the question i'll ask the
question different way i'll ask the
question a different way so uh for
example
okay
uh you know we'll talk about mafia
states of america we'll give an update
before the whole thing ends because
people need to know what's going on with
that but hypothetically okay
um how many total hours have we put into
mafia states of america total everybody
team
you know think about where we were at
shooting
40 people they're editors can we say
i don't know total everybody 10 000
hours is that a fair number
maybe more okay let's just say ten
thousand hours ago let's just say ten
thousand hours now
uh i the the funder is gonna sit there
and say why is this costing so much
money it's taking so many hours it's
freaking ridiculous i don't have
manpower to get these guys to edit other
projects i have nine editors working on
this one project gerard this is freaking
ridiculous right however however
if
when we're done qcing all of it this
week which is going to release december
3rd we are done
putting any time into it because now
it's up there then i'm good meaning
if that energy is required to mine a
bitcoin it's just the energy required
until you mine it then it's good to go
it doesn't require any more energy we're
fine no but is it a constant energy
required to sustain it because that's a
concern so the other thing that occurs
is that uh you are
a transaction processor as well so the
same people that are mining the bitcoins
are also processing the transactions so
as transactions occur that that's also
part of the consumption on btc it's
almost none comparatively sure but bsv
for example has more transaction uh
more of what's going on on that network
is transactions than it is mining so
and and this is this is why i say like
look if if we're building a world that
is disruptive it is more efficient it's
more
fair in a way that is verifiable not
arbitrarily fair but like look at the
math look kirk to me that's a complete
red herring man i mean you know if
you're using five percent of the world's
energy that's governmental that's that's
not people in their in their backyard on
their computers that means that world
governments are using a lot of their
energy grid to be able to do that right
el salvador specifically one of these
countries that's moving to it as their
primary currency the other thing about
that is is that our energy production is
only just beginning remember a hundred
years ago you know the world war one
started and calvary was still involved
like world war one began and they were
still i believe it was poland was going
up against tanks in actual with horses
yeah so i mean we basically just came
out of the middle ages guys 100 100
years from now our energy capacity is
going to be something that we can't even
really begin to understand so so i think
i think the other thing to know about
power right now is that that there is
more power generated than is used so
until we actually get to the point where
we're putting real strain on the grid i
think it's an irrelevant compound
haven't even captured the power of the
sun man
but even right now as inefficient as our
power generation is we're generating too
much power even with bitcoin and even
with all the other inefficiencies that
are perceived we're creating more energy
than is used my big issue with like to
me that that's an obvious you know to me
and again everybody's a communist right
but i mean to me that that's just an
obvious hit piece
so what does concern me is a little bit
of the decentralization like who can
take over bitcoin pat talked about a
fiat currency for people that don't know
basically it means that that the united
states dollar isn't backed by anything
there's nothing back there's no gold
standard you can't tie it to anything
there's nothing your paper dollar in
your pocket is based on nothing more
than faith it's as real as satoshi all
right it's
it really is it's as real so you know
the the but bitcoin doesn't have
aircraft carriers so there's that aspect
of it you know so you know our fed
reserve
for as bad as it is and i i think it the
fed reserve and and the wbo are two of
the most evil organizations on earth i
really honestly believe that with every
fiber in my being
and they sell for people that don't know
the federal reserve isn't even a
government agency it's a private bank
that sells money to the united states we
buy our money folks the money then your
pocket is worth less the second you get
it than the second it was printed we buy
our money from a private bank so
moving away from this like pat said i
think is is absolutely crucial to every
american citizens also why they'll never
let us do it number one number two
what is to stop bitcoin from from
becoming a world back currency let's say
and then somebody like calvin air being
like oh yeah by the way i own this and
now you guys have to pay this price or
this or that like what what's to stop
that from happening well i think first
of all
the way that it's distributed first of
all like there's a reason why it wasn't
distributed by you know craig wright
patent this and that copyright this and
that it's it's cop it's actually
copywritten to satoshi nakamoto and it's
got an open source mit license so it's
basically look modify it if you want do
what you want to it but if you make a
modification you need to change the name
so if it's bitcoin it's bitcoin run
bitcoin and then the way that it's
distributed the way that it's processed
and everything is 100 competitive again
it is a pure free market function and
this is why it really matters this is
why i don't like with btc that the the
bip process and this what has really
become democratic socialism in the way
that
that changes are made and changes are
implemented in btc i think it's a major
problem bitcoin is supposed to be
governed 100 by proof-of-work and if
everybody agrees that look you need to
compete to create the most value but
even there before you move on from that
kurt who governs it
like how is it governable who's holding
each other accountable like what is the
process of that accountability we can
say it's proof of work but you know also
if there's no fines or penalties like
but there is that's the point of proof
of work if you do something that is
unsavory to the other nodes in the
network if your proof of work appears to
be malicious they can just simply say
you know what we're done with you we're
not going that direction the proof of
work will orphan your ideas off of the
network that's the beauty of it is that
if you aren't creating value the second
you have decided maybe i'm going to be a
malicious king you will cease to be the
king period we've seen it hundreds of
times in bitcoin every time there used
to be the the bit main oh bit maine is
going to take over and they're this this
big conglomerate and ultimately people
are like you know what we don't like bit
main we're just basically going to do
things that make them go away and
they've they've had to completely change
they've reorganized
you can obviously see the next logical
step in that is okay now china just
comes in overwhelms the system and says
everything that that's not pro us we can
orphan the same way but but they really
can't because again it's based on its
principle and proof of work so if they
come in
with with something that again is
malicious to the network the network
itself is anti-fragile in that it can
say we're basically going to go a
different direction i understand what
that means the network is it ai the
network no it's people yeah it's it's
it's competitive people are corruptable
a person is corruptable if in a perfect
free market system i believe that in a
perfect free market system we will still
have malicious actors we'll still have
serial killers we'll have these things
but if we are all able to compete 100 to
be
anything we can be if we can cooperate
better whoever cooperates best will win
and they should win but the way that
they win is by creating the most value
for the rest of everyone else so i would
actually hope that communist china says
okay we need to mine we need to
participate in this economic disruption
by being a node on the network because
it will create incentives that make them
better people too
that's that's my desire i want
governments to stop having cold wars and
hot wars with each other i want them to
have to mine about it they need to brute
force their ideas that's what mining is
it is brute forcing to find the best
path forward and i would rather have
these things brute forced rather than
we're invading each other's countries or
whatever so if you enjoyed this little
short segment from the podcast that we
did here's another short segment to
watch or if you want to see the entire
podcast click over here take care
everybody bye
[Music]